a lot of people don't don't start
thinking about this I think until they
get
older and thinking about death thinking
about the meaning of their life you know
they get in their 40s or 50s suddenly
you know they're they're about something
different um sometimes this coincides
with a midlife crisis
right what are the kinds of things that
people want to leave
behind some people want to be remembered
for great
you know you talk about
Achilles fighting all that um other
people leave behind poetic Works he
talks about Homer and hassad you know
who wouldn't want to have children like
they do what did they leave behind Homer
Left Behind The Odyssey and The Iliad
two really great classic works that have
stood the test of time um Plato himself
is is leaving behind children like that